I want to talk a little bit about the
sort of damage control that we've seen
from Donald Trump after this first
debate on Monday some people emailed me
after my analysis yesterday saying well
David specifically why did Donald Trump
quote lose the debate luster one can be
a little difficult to define I mean
really what's going to determine that is
the impact on the polls and we're not
going to have post debate polling until
probably Friday maybe not until next
Monday so what I think we can really
focus in on and are what are the ways in
which Donald Trump did not do as well as
Hillary Clinton obviously Trump's
knowledge of issues is far far far
behind Hillary Clinton's but my big
reaction is who expected anything else
right who expected to watch this debate
and say you know I was just stunned by
how much Donald Trump knew we know that
he doesn't know anything so he
completely bungled several areas the
question on the birther birth
certificate stuff was an absolute
disaster for Donald Trump the questions
about cyber cyber ring where he
mentioned his 10 year old kid is just so
good with computers if you're running
for president and someone asks you about
cyber warfare
my first instinct would not be to
mention how your 10 year old kid has
computers at home ok that's that's not
what I would go towards mentioning that
it's smart not to pay federal taxes
these are really really disasters so
Trump gets embarrassed at the debate
really badly people who have a clue
recognize this I know low information
voters and people who personally just
hate Hillary Clinton probably thought
Trump did an okay job but he really
really did embarrass himself Trump goes
into damage control mode damage control
mode is even more of a disaster than the
debate performance first he barrels into
the spin room which normally the
candidate doesn't show up at the spin
room your surrogates show up and starts
spinning for you he claims his
microphone was defective I told you
about that yesterday no evidence
whatsoever that the microphone was
defective Hillary Clinton said very
astutely anyone complaining about
microphones was not having a good night
I couldn't agree more and in the spin
room he contradicts many of the things
he said during the debate during the
debate he said he was smart not to pay
federal taxes in the spin room he denied
having said it altogether
about moderator Lester Holt in the spin
room he said I thought Lester Holt did a
good job six hours later roughly six
hours later early the next morning on
Fox & Friends
Trump changes the story altogether and
says Oh Lester Holt gave me very unfair
questions I give him a C or a C+ I
thought he was okay
drastic drastic change and it is just
damage control gone awry and the most
outlandish of trumps claims about the
debate was that he said there was no
sniffle the sniffling that distracted so
many viewers Trump denied it period no
sniffles let's take a look and listen to
the following video you tell me if there
was sniffling here yeah why even deny it
I have no idea that went on and on and
on what's the big picture trend here
what is it that we can learn from this
and apply it to how Donald Trump would
be as president well number one he has
excuses for everything right the guy
takes no accountability for his actions
whatsoever he will blame everything from
the moderator
to a faulty microphone and all sorts of
made-up ideas about as to why his
performance was what it was but more
importantly Trump is completely
unconcerned dand unaffected by the truth
and I think Pat was spot on in the last
segment when he said that in spite of
the constant lies and and lack of
accountability and taking responsibility
Trump still polls better on honest and
trustworthiness than does Hillary
Clinton and he is definitely taking
advantage of that and the saddest part
about all of this is that Donald Trump
should never even have made it this far
to the point where we have to do this
type of analysis that's really what I
can't get past Rachel which is if the
world made sense and it really doesn't
someone like Donald Trump would never be
on this debate stage in the first place
and these ridiculous analyses of dozens
of lies that the guy told we wouldn't
have to do them because he has no place
on that stage to begin with right but
there's no evidence that the lying is
going to stop because in his first
speech post debates he opened in Florida
by telling a lie saying that oh actually
I'm actually pulling bad
in terms of who people thought one yeah
in this debate it's me it's me granted
he did have his trusty teleprompter here
yeah and also his default would just be
to redirect blame back to the media yeah
well I'm guessing he was referring to
that very very scientifically done
Drudge Report dot-com insta poll that
showed him winning something like five
to one I mean here the funny thing about
some of these polls people are pointing
to is even if you think Trump did really
well the country is not going to think
by an 80 to 20 margin that Trump won I
mean in in the best of cases if Trump
really does well because we know how
polarized our country is in terms of
politics Trump might have a 60 to 40
edge if he if he had like the the best
possible performance against Hillary
Clinton 80 the fact that 80 anybody 180
22 me are our numbers that I would
definitely question but to put a finer
point on what you said Rachel not only
is there no evidence that Donald Trump
is going to stop the lying anytime soon
we have every reason to believe that the
lying and excuses and lack of taking
responsibility would only continue if
Donald Trump was President of the United
States so the damage control you know
how they say the cover-up is often worse
than the thing itself the damage control
for Trump has been even worse than the
debate itself you disagree I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman you can let me know
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing